we're in for a treat here's everything
new coming to gameplay and fifa 23.
can't wait to hear more about
hypermotion 2. let's throw it to sheldon
and our gameplay team to dive into the
details thank you derek joined by the
one and only shauna games and our
gameplay dev team sam and concho
everyone how you doing good good thanks
doing good how are you i'm super excited
to play for you for 23. cheers for our
skin
okay let's get right into it today we're
talking about hypermotion 2 women's
football attacking defending goalkeepers
and shawna's favorite skill moves first
let's start with high promotion 2 what
we got so high promotion is our
groundbreaking next gen technology that
combines advanced 11 vs 11 match capture
with machine learning and with high
promotion 2 this year for fifa 23 we
carried out twice as much real world
motion capture than we did last year
that's two
full high intensity matches with
training drills oh wow that sounds
amazing that's right so there was like a
shooting drill we got a ton of great
data for power shots and goalkeepers we
also did one on one so a lot of new
dribbles and the way the defender
jockeyed and try to counter that dribble
we've got all that motion so the beauty
of training drills is that we can get a
high volume of data that maybe you would
see only once or twice in a full 90
minute match but in the training drills
we got it over and over again in a short
period of time
and hyper motion 2 is a technology that
empowers the improvements across all the
gameplay areas and in the end it takes
us over 6 000 new true to football
animations transferred from the pitch
directly into the game yeah and don't
forget our machine learning algorithm
it's learning from over 9 million frames
of data that we captured from these
accents motion capture shoots so so to
sum it up it's more motion capture data
than we've ever captured before and
they're professional athletes playing
competitive matches and that's what's
going into the game feeding our
animation and ai systems
well i'm super excited you guys are
representing women's club football now
in fifa what was it like working with
the professional women's team this time
around it was amazing that we captured
two professional women's teams and now
that we have women's club teams in fifa
23. it's bringing authenticity to the
women's game we've captured all this
real world data where they you know they
played a competitive match and now all
of that can be felt in the game
and i know that besides they capture the
specific animations for the passing and
the shooting we actually
completely changed the whole locomotion
set for the female players it means like
every run in style will be feel unique
and more realistic
[Applause]
what does all of this unlock in making
the hyper motion 2 experience feel more
authentic from the first moment you pick
up fifa 23 you're gonna notice that
dribbling is different
we've used the new animations that
hypermotion brings to enhance the
responsiveness and the visual quality of
dribbling
and it adds a whole new level of
personality when you're playing with
elite dribblers you're gonna be able to
change directions much more quickly it's
more based on real world football but
what the tech allows us to do is
actually interrupt dribble animations so
that even if you point to the right side
you can quickly change to the left and
we'll interrupt that turbo animation to
allow you to sort of like create a
almost like a body faint motion where
you're shifting your weight from one
side to the other to help you beat that
opponent and the new dribbling system is
compatible with the machine learning
ammo flow that introduced last year
which means we can ensure the clean
footsteps in between every dribble touch
right and then people always ask well
what's the counter to dribbling surely
there's something in defending well
that's where the new machine learning
jockey comes in so the way you're able
to position your body the way you're
able to angle up to that dribbler is
much more intelligent yeah and i know
that the jockey allows you to have this
super smooth quick lateral movement in
and out step-ins change of direction
well i love using the jockey button so
i'll definitely be using this to cart or
the dribbling please tell me more guys
another part of the high promotion that
i'm super excited is accelerate we know
that the pace speed
and acceleration those attributes is
probably the very first thing that our
players look into exactly like
acceleration is very important yeah
inspired by the life players we defined
three acceleration archetypes
the explosive controlled and lengthy the
length is the strong physical players
but it's not only limited to defenders
some of the strong physical attackers
will also benefit from this archetype
which means they might be not as fast on
the very short distance but will be able
to accelerate and their long powerful
strides to really improve their speed
and accelerate even further and get the
edge over the longer distances
i know that most of the players will be
using the controlled which is more
continuous acceleration but i really
like the other archetype the explosive
one which is dedicated to agile players
like those midfielders in the center of
the pitch because they might not be
associated with the pc and the long runs
but they have that killer quick first
step oh wow they're literally coming so
fast after mark and it's not just the
acceleration types that we have that are
new this year we also have signature run
styles for those top players i know
embape is one we've got his unique
running motion in the game right now i
know there was a few other players that
you were keen to talk about sam yeah my
favorite one is venusius jr because he
actually has a two visually different
run styles when he's drilling with the
ball and without you can see when he's
dribbling with the ball his hands a
little bit everywhere because he's so
creative going in and out but when he
runs he's more composed and i know
there's a series of the small
subtle changes in the way their arms
move and the elbows move doing dribbling
during running doing jogging and the
collection of those small changes really
makes a difference oh wow that's sick
seeing so many new additions on the
hypermotion side but there's really a
lot happening in gameplay overall this
year let's start on the offensive side
of the ball sam what's your favorite way
of scoring a goal my favorite one is the
powershot powershot is a new high risk
high reward mechanic that requires a
little bit more precision from you but
at the same time it will result in one
of the most powerful
most exquisite animation i've ever seen
in fifa games with power shots you can
actually do this in in a number of
different ways you can take it off the
dribble or
you can take it first time top bins all
day every day for sure for shauna always
going for the top bins but as we eye the
back of the net here is there anything
else to help players score more goals
last year we introduced composed ball
control this year composed ball striking
allows players to control the ball with
that first touch and set themselves up
for a volley or like a bicycle kick you
take one touch to control the ball and
then fluidly step into the shot so the
the beauty of it is that you're setting
yourself up with that thigh touch or
that chest touch so that you can really
step into it with power for the shot
and now to an area where we have a
little more time to find different ways
to score what's new with set pieces in
fifa 23. in fifa 23 we redesigned all
set pieces mechanics the new penalty
kicks will have a more intuitive aiming
system but the key piece of the penalty
kicks this year is a new circle shape
composure bar if you time it right
you will have a more precise shot which
means you can also power it a little bit
more
yeah that brings us to free kicks
something the community highlights so
often anything new here players can look
forward to with the new system with the
right stick you are able to pinpoint the
exact place on the ball you're about to
strike and i really love that the new
system gives you full control of the
trajectory so in certain situations i
can actually curl around the wall back
into the net and the opponent will have
no idea i can do that my favorite thing
is on defense you can actually lie down
behind the wall to block any low shots
when the wall is jumping you see that in
real football all the time these days
sam the back line is starting to sweat
right now how how on earth are we going
to counter all of this on the defensive
side
every year we're trying to keep up with
the attacking with all the new ways to
score and on defender there are several
improvements we had in this year and my
favorite one is the hard slide
this feature was designed to send the
ball as far away as possible but i found
it quite useful as a counter attack to
the power shots because if you need some
time to prepare for a shot this is a
perfect opportunity for me to
unexpectedly go and keep the ball as far
away as possible
and i know we've added a ton of new
animations just for the elite defenders
so more coverage to stop the ball even
if you've sort of overrun the ball you
can reach back and still get your toe
onto it so really nice way to make those
world-class defenders stand out
[Applause]
naturally we've made our way to the last
line of defense what's new in
goalkeeping this year
so with keepers we've added this
reaction time based on their vision so
if their vision is blocked they're going
to be a bit slower to react so more
natural behaviors from the goalkeeper
but when they do have time to go up and
grab that ball they're going to be
stronger even if an opponent is
challenging for the ball they're going
to keep that ball even if they fall down
they're gonna hold on to it just like
you see in real life
exactly exactly there's probably some
other cool stuff that we haven't talked
about like the fingers yeah yeah we
always wanted to add this for a long
time when the goalkeeper will really
stretch out the reaching for the ball
and you will be able to see like each
finger deformation coming up with the
contact with the ball and this you were
able to achieve this and my favorite
part that this new physics approach was
able to recreate not only for the
goalkeeper but also for the defenders so
this year
the ball will actually graze over the
foot will graze over the leg and there
will be more deflections and not only
does it graze off the deflection it
actually pushes back like the foot or
the arm
i know sean has been dying to ask you
this shauna this is loki my favorite
part skill moves what's new tell me
everything about it please i'm dying to
know
there's so many new things with skill
moves actually but my favorite part is
the left-footed skill moves this is
something the community has been asking
for for many years and we finally got
that into the game so if you're mars for
example you can actually do an elastico
skill and he'll use his left foot to do
that now
there's so many other skill moves to
talk about like mbappe right the way he
fakes a shot i really love the fake
shots because it's one of the easiest
and most reliable skill modes to perform
in the game and i know that this is
available only to to the elite players
and we also have a stutter faint skill
move where they faint one way and make
you step the wrong direction
my favorite new skill moves is a heel
fake to ball roll
it's good i mean i've been using it
already in the game and it's a skill
move where you actually use the heel to
fake a pass and then you do a ball roll
to the other direction
oh wow that's sick well this is going to
be great content for me totally i'm
loving all of these new updates coming
to fifa 23 from women's football to new
shooting mechanics to all new ways to
defend and your first look at what
hypermotion 2 is bringing to the game
that does it from the pitch derek back
to you thank you very much for that
can't wait to lend our commentary to the
world's game this year
[Music]
you